ja willkommen zur Vorlesung Philosophie
der virtuellen Realität sie wundern sich
bestimmt kann man darüber auch
philosophieren ist doch gar nicht klar
was virtuelle Realität ist wir sind
aller Munde des Thema aber völlig unklar
was ist eigentlich philosophisch
bedeutet
erstmal ist völlig unklar was eigentlich
Virtualität bedeutet was bedeutet
virtuell das virtuell ist und genauso
unklar ist vielleicht noch viel unklarer
ist der Begriff der Realität da streiten
sich die Philosophie und Philosophen
schon seit Jahrhunderten wenn ich davon
über 1000 sind und jetzt wollen wir hier
diese beiden Begriffe aufeinander
beziehen und nicht nur Realität ist
schon schwer genug ist auch noch
virtuelle Realität da haben wir uns
einiges vorgenommen
da sind also ungefähr wissen was heute
sie erwartet ich sage jetzt was von
alles Veranstaltung dann Training machen
wir eine Einführung in diese Thematik
anhand dieses Films ready Player one wer
von ihnen hat den schon mal gesehen
ready Player one auch hier so ein paar
wir schauen uns so eine Sequenz an die
ich sehr zentral finde dann stelle ich
so ein paar neue via also Virtual
Reality Medien vor auch anhand von
Werbevideos also ich kann schon so viel
sagen es ist keine Werbeveranstaltung
ich will sie hier gar nicht irgendwie
ihr drängen sich irgendwie ein Gerät
bei Apple wird das auch teuer genug sein
sie wissen was dieses Apple Vision
kostet über 3000 €, ist noch gar nicht
auf dem Markt aber ich will ihn trotzdem
mal zeigen was ich so technologisch tut
es ist also ein Thema virtuelle
Realitäten die starken
technikaffin ist technologisch
Dimensionen hat aber die eben nicht
darin aufgehen das ist mir ganz wichtig
hier rüberzubringen es geht hier nicht
in dieser Vorlesung um
schwierig Philosophie darum soll es
nicht gehen das ist sicherlich eine
Dimension virtuelle Realität die Technik
hallo aber sie ist nicht das ganze
virtuelle Realität da müssen wir noch
ein bisschen weiter gehen und dennoch
müssen wir mit diesen Medien uns
auseinandersetzen auch wenn ich glaube
dass die philosophische Bedeutung
virtuelle Realität nicht in solchen
Brillen aufgeht die wir uns auch ziehen
über den Kopf stöbeln es ist glaube ich
zu kurz aber das müssen wir jetzt
genauer begründen und ich begründe diese
These mit der Ideengeschichte der
Begriffsgeschichte zum Begriff der
Virtualität das habe ich an der
Ankündigung geschrieben wir gehen da
ganz zurück zu den Wurzeln der
Philosophie wir gehen auf Platten eines
Todes
Leibnitz kann und unterwegs ein ähm das
sind alles Dinge die bis in die
Neuzeit reichen zumindest bei krank und
schauen was haben die zum Begriff der
Virtualität gesagt
und Sie werden feststellen die sagen
ganz
komplexes schwieriges dazu was nicht nur
heißt dass wir uns in einer Simulation
befinden weil so besteht man häufig
virtuelle Realität als Simulation aber
sie werden sehen Sie Virtualität wird
von diesen denken nicht als Simulation
verstanden und da sind ganz
interessanter Finger zeigen enthalten
für eine genuin philosophische
Thematisierung
und dann wollen wir natürlich nicht nur
bei der Geschichte der Philosophie
bleiben sondern wir wollen auch die
Gegenwart vorstoßen und dazu uns mit
Philosophen wie David scharmes und
Michael rein und
Germania vielleicht haben sie diesen
Namen schon gehört das sind alles
überwiegend Denker aus dem
Westen der USA schon vorher das ist kein
Wunder weil er Kalifornien die ganzen
technologischen Großindustrien
beheimatet sind ja Metapher
aber auch die ganze
Technik und die Grafikkarten die
Nvidia zum Beispiel also solche großen
technologischen Tech-Unternehmen die uns
eben auch grafische Anwendungen zur
Verfügung stellen die sind dort
beheimatet und nicht ohne Grund kommen
eben auch viele dieser bis hin viele
dieser neueren denke virtuelle Realität
durch diese
Industrien
beeinflussen
und dann wollen wir heute zum Schluss
uns überlegen wie verhalten sich
eigentlich diese Begriffe Virtualität
kreieren Simulation
Illusion zueinander da habe ich Ihnen
jetzt schon ein Angebot gemacht
besser zum Zentrum stehen und Vorlesen
diese Begriffe und diese Begriffe in
eine sinnvolle
Ordnung zu bringen also zu schauen
inwiefern kann Realität virtuell sein
wir sagen ja virtuelle Realität dann
kann man sich weiterfahren wenn wir
jetzt schon Realität sprechen die
virtuell ist inwiefern ist sie dann nur
eine Simulation nicht verträgt sich
Realität mit Simulationen wenn wir sagen
das ist doch nur eine Simulation sagen
wir doch eigentlich das ist aber nicht
die harte Welt
genauso wenn wir sagen was ist die
Illusion dann würden wir auch sagen das
ist jetzt aber nicht die Realität wenn
ich in der Wüste bin und eine Vater
Morgana sehe dann dann sehe ich eine
Illusionen bin ich getäuscht wenn ich
jetzt aber sagt er ist tatsächlich eine
Oase sind die wir durch die
vorgespielt wird dann irre ich mich dann
ist es nicht die Realität natürlich ist
es real dass ich die
Illusionen habe das ist ja aber die also
an einer Oase ne das ist real,-
tatsächlich deine Oase der Wüste ist
da irre ich mich dann und genau so ist
es mit dem Begriff der Funktion wir
werden sehen es virtuelle Realität wie
wir es heute kennen mit diesen Brillen
und auch diese Simulation hat sehr viel
zu tun
weil wir hier auch ein künstliche Welt
eintreten können was Science-Fiction ist
ja ein riesen Schlagwort und in der
Fiktion da verschwinden Simulation da
wird etwas simuliert es wird aber auch
ins illusiv näher gebracht und es wird
sogar gestellt als Professionalität
zeigen kann man sich natürlich
inwiefern ist das am Ende doch irgendwie
real das sind natürlich wieder davon ab
was wir unter Realitäten bestehen das
will ich heute machen dass mein Programm
für heute morgen oder nächsten Tagen
wenden uns dann konkreteren Themen zu
konkreten von virtuelle Realität wir
nehmen morgen fliegt und Onkologie
virtuelle Realität ich sage dazu gleich
noch was Ontologie meint ja was ist das
eigentlich für eine Realität mit der wir
es jetzt zu tun haben wir verstehen
darunter auch Gegenstände virtuelle
Gegenstände sie kennen sicherlich
Bitcoins schon mal gehört das Finden
virtuelle Gegenstände genauer gesagt
digitale virtuelle Gegenstände es geht
nämlich auch virtuelle Gegenstände die
nicht digital sind das ist überhaupt ein
großes Thema auch noch wie verhält sich
virtuelle Realität zu Digitalisierung es
virtuelle Realität nur ein
Bereich ein Teil des großthemas
Digitalisierung oder gibt es nicht schon
virtuelle Realität oder gab es das schon
vor dieser neuen digitalen
Transformation ich vertrete these
virtuelle Realität ist so alt wie der
Mensch und gibt es nicht erst seitdem
wir diese neuen digitalen Medien haben
also auch das ist ein spannendes Thema
das Virtualität
und Digitalisierung oder Digitalität
diesen Begriff werde ich auch verwenden
was das ist werde ich dann sagen also
morgen geht's um Ontologie oder nicht
darauf folgenden Tagen geht es um die
Ethik also virtuellen Realität auch das
spannende weil sie haben bestimmt schon
was von sogenannten
Universum gehört das netterversum da
gehen wir heute auch noch drauf ein
virtuellen Handlungsraum bestimmen also
ein virtuelle Welt in der wir nicht nur
etwas konsumieren oder simulieren sind
auch tatsächlich realisieren im
Mittagessen können Sie Dinge kaufen sie
können mit anderen Person kommunizieren
und da wo sie mit anderen Personen
kommunizieren oder interagieren da
stellt sich auch die Frage ob das
moralisch gut oder schlecht ist da
stellt sich auf die Frage ob wir
vielleicht sogar auch manchmal virtuelle
schlecht
interagieren oder Dinge tun virtuellen
nicht okay sind dann muss man sich
fragen Geld für das wird schon andere
Regeln als für das physische das nicht
virtuelle wir müssen auch schauen
virtuelle Realität
also diese Frage ist glaube ich 14 Tage
wenn man bis immer so tut als Zeit alles
virtuelle doch nur Spielerei und als
könnte man dort alles machen sie werden
sehen einige der neueren Denker sagen
virtuelle Realität hat etwas mit wildem
Westen zu tun und sie wissen im Wilden
Westen galten wir es auch keine
wirklichen Gesetze das musste erst zu
langsam im gesetzmäßige Form geführt
werden jetzt kann man sich genauso
Fragen gehen in der virtuellen Realität
überhaupt irgendwelche Gesetze
moralische Vorschriften ich glaube schon
aber wir müssen uns genau überlegen wie
diese Gesetze diese moralischen Aspekte
zu bewerten sind weil virtuelle Realität
eben doch in manchen Hinsicht anders ist
als physische Realität Stichwort und
Zeit das wird zu meinem Rückzug sein in
der virtuellen Realität haben wir einen
anderen Raum und Zeit bezogen als in der
physischen Realität hier sind sie alle
Verordnung diesen Satz physisch präsent
in der virtuellen Realität sind wir auf
eine andere Weise präsent nicht nur
physisch nur virtuell und auch die Zeit
scheint ein bisschen andere Rolle zu
spielen und davon hängt dann am Ende
auch wie wir überhaupt integrieren was
ist überhaupt eine virtuelle Handlung
wie können wir überhaupt virtuell
interagieren und wie sollten wir dieses
Handeln dann bewerten das ist also eine
große Thematik in dieser Woche noch
Behandlung und dann werden wir uns auch
mit dem Thema Kunst beschäftigen
Ästhetik der virtuellen Realität
was ist ein virtuelles Kunstwerk und zum
Schluss werden wir uns mit der Frage
nach der Anthropologie befassen was ist
der Mensch angesichts des virtuellen
kann der Menschen einen virtuellen
Existenz haben sie denken vielleicht
gleich an sowas wie Transhumanismus an
mein Upload dass wir unser Gehirn sein
unsere geistiges ich in die
Digitalisierung übertragen solche
Spekulation gibt es auch schon seit
einiger Zeit und das werden wir auch
gemeinsam hier kritisch diskutieren
ich habe schon gesagt die Veranstaltung
ist übrigens das heißt sie wird auch
aufgezeichnet zumindest nur das was ich
sage die Diskussion nicht wird auch
viele gestellt ich sag gleich ein
bisschen was dazu Diskussionen nicht
aufgezeichnet es gibt auch krisse ähm
ich mache zu jeder Sitzung ein paar
Joyce
Fragen die sie dann online auch starten
können
müssen auch in Echtzeit überprüfen ich
sage das noch genau und ich schicke
Ihnen nach jeder Sitzung eine
zusammenfassende Ergebnisse weil ich
daraus dann am Ende ein Buch mache ist
ja ganz praktisch da kann ich schon mal
das ganze mit ihnen jetzt hier
diskutieren auch gerne im Internet und
in deinem Kommentarbereich auf Youtube
gerne Kommentare lassen und dann nehme
ich die gerne auf diese Anregung wenn
sie positiv sind
zum formalen sie können hier ein
unbenotetes Ergebnisprotokoll Verfassen
von ca 10 Seiten bitte kein bloßes
Verlaufsprotokoll also nicht sagen erst
hat der Dozent das gesagt
orientieren Sie sich dabei an den
systematischen Fragen und Problemen ja
also was ist das Problem gewesen diese
vorlesen
es waren die Lösung was ist eine offen
so sollten
Verfassung Zeitabstand 1,5 Punkte
mit Deckblatt bitte bitte aus dem auch
ihr Name die Matrikelnummer
hervorgehen
die Folie nochmal per E-Mail rum sie
brauchen alles notieren und stellen die
auch auf System
filocast hatte ich schon erwähnt das ist
mein YouTube-Kanal der hat jetzt schon
fast 6000 Abonnenten da bin ich ganz
stolz drauf und auf diesen Kanal einfach
Youtube Video dann die aufzeichnen
es gibt auch eine App für Smartphones
als Android und Apple Geräte wobei ich
gehört habe das ist auch den Apple Gerät
noch besser laufen soll also Sie können
sich die pilocast herunterladen über
diese App können Sie sich dann auch
diese Aufzeichnung anschalten und sie
können auch das Quiz können Sie machen
schon sehen Sie und das ist ein Symbol
für ein Quiz dann können Sie mal schauen
aus der Ecke starten und so sieht dann
das ist aus jetzt von dem Homepage
kilokasten.net
in welchem lateinischen Wort leitet ab
können Sie jetzt schon überlegen was ist
ich habe hier dann ein paar Angebote
gemacht klicken
und dann kriegen sie
die Antwort angezeigt und ich gebe Ihnen
auch ein paar Hinweise wenn Sie die
falsche Frage angekreuzt haben sollten
bekommen sie noch eine automatische
Rückmeldung also das ganze ist ein
bisschen interaktiv das möchte ich Ihnen
zeigen und dann natürlich eigentlich
unser Logo also sie werden dieses
Figürchen immer wieder kennenlernen das
hat damit etwas Besonderes auch sich
dieses Figürchen habe ich selbst
erstellen lassen mit Hilfe von k.i
nämlich mit dort vielleicht hast
also eingegeben virtuelle Realität und
das wurde mir ausgegeben und sehen das
sind bei
Assoziationen es ist eine Brille die um
den Kopf geschnallt wird und es sind
vielleicht aus der Handschuhe so ein
bisschen das sind diese Steuerelement
die eben der neue
Technologie häufig vorhanden sind
teilweise sogar auch nicht mehr
erwischen hat gar keine Controller mehr
das machen wir damit mit dem großen
Hände heute genau sehen
ja und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen eben diese
Leitfaden präsentieren und die sind auch
verdammt für ihr Protokoll wichtig ich
werde auch immer wieder auch wiederholen
damit sie vor Augen haben der
besteologie als ihr kenntnisstheorie
inwiefern handelt es bei virtueller
Realität um eine bloße Simulation oder
Illusion und wie hängt sie mit
individuellen und kollektiven
systemischen Akteuren zusammen
individuelle kollektive Akteure es
Handeln individuelle Personen wie Sie
und ich der virtuellen Realität aber es
handelt vielleicht auch Unternehmen oder
Gruppen oder sonstige Person Verbünde
vielleicht sogar auch künstliche
Intelligenz sind handeln die auch in der
virtuellen Welt das müssen wir uns
aufbauen also künstliche Intelligenz
wird hier auch immer mit reinspringen
die Ontologie in die existieren
virtuelle Realitäten und die Verhalten
sie zu körperlichen Dingen zu physischen
redenszeit
1 2 € Stück liegt hier auf diesem Tisch
vielleicht oder könnte hier liegen hier
das hat eine Ausdehnung es liegt zu
dieser Zeit hier wie verhält es sich mit
ihren Bitcoins die sie angesammelt haben
hoffentlich zur rechten Seite
oder auch nicht ja wo existieren die ja
existieren die auch irgendwo in einem
Server dort an dieser Stelle wo diese
noch nicht einzeln sind was für eine
Ausdehnung hat dieser
kann man denn überhaupt physisch
begreifen macht es überhaupt Sinn
physisch dieses diesen Bitcoins zu
verstehen und wie lange existiert oder
wann existierte seit wann also solche
Fragen sehen Sie schon werden immer
schwieriger wenn man zu stellen als
beantworten wenn man sie auch virtuitiv
Ethik habe ich schon gesagt wir sind das
sind überhaupt virtuelle Handlungen
denken
und virtuelle Handlungsräume und
inwiefern können wir sie moralisch
beurteilen und normativ definieren heißt
welche moralischen Gesetze sollten im
virtuellen handlungsfall Geld ist das
ein virtueller Bilder der besten eine
schöne Alliteration virtuell Wilder
Westen oder Geld auch hier Regeln gelten
dieselben moralischen Regeln oder
juristischen Regeln sie sehen schon die
Rechtswissenschaft hat große Probleme
das Wetter wäre es um juristisch zu
bestimmen
was ist Eigentum im Metaversum es gibt
jetzt auch neuerdings die Möglichkeit
dort virtuellen Ort virtuellen Räume
virtuelle Gegenden zu kaufen so neu ist
natürlich das metaversion nicht
vielleicht alle dieses Spiel Second Life
schon mal gehört second line also so neu
ist die Sache auch wieder nicht der
Gedanke des Universums besteht darin
dass wir eben ganz verschiedene
Praktiken und vor allem auch
Arbeitsformen
virtualisiert werden können das war bei
Second Life so noch nicht der Fall aber
ich komme darauf zu sprechen
Ästhetik habe ich schon gesagt ungefähr
lässt sich Kunst virtualisieren was es
überhaupt virtuelle Kunst wird für die
Museen welchen ästhetischen Status
besitzen Computerspiele computerspiele
sind in meinen Augen ein guter Kandidat
wird
und darüber werden
Psychologie inwiefern können wir
virtuell also nicht müssen existieren
welche Rolle spielt unser Körper
angesichts virtueller Realitäten noch
könnt ihr denken wenn wir eine virtuelle
Existenz haben dann spielt unser Körper
keine Rolle mehr und den Körper ist ja
nur physisch vergänglich und eigentlich
nur lästig für das Äußerliche was für
die Virtualisierung keine Rolle spielen
weil wir ja in beliebige Avatare
Schnupfen können wir können beliebige
Rollen annehmen wir können Superheld
sein Superhelden so wie es uns recht das
werden wir gleich noch sehen dann hat
dieses System
[Musik]
unser Körper ist auch in der virtuellen
Realität wichtig weil unser Körper
zu Schnittstelle für die virtuelle
Realität z.B wenn Sie jetzt bei Vision
pro dieses Headset zeichnet
sehr toll wenn sie dann nur mit ihren
Fingern etwas steuern und dann sehen sie
da wird Ihr Körper selbst zum Medium
virtuelle Welt
also da wird Ihr Körper wirklich
eingesetzt in die virtuelle Realität und
nicht nur abgeschieden als es gibt zwei
Ansichten bezüglich des Verhältnisses
von virtuellen virtueller Realität und
Körperlichkeit oder genauer Leiblichkeit
eine sagt Körper und Leitung sind uns
gelassen werden nur noch
digitaler mind Upload also die
existieren nur noch als
virtualisiertes Gehirn als Software
letztendlich lassen unseren Sterblichen
endlichen Körper zurück oder die andere
aufweisen die sagt nein unser Körper
genau wie gesagt der muss in die
virtuellen Politik mit einbezogen werden
Gestik Berührung lässt sich wunderbar
ins virtuelle überführen unser Leiter
zum Medium
Realität diese Ansatz ist mir wie Sie
sich denken können sympathische weil
solche Szenarien wie mein uplo
touristisch klingen und häufig
spekulativen Gehalt haben aber darüber
werden wir jetzt treffen diskutieren
ja Methode der Vorlesung ich werde erst
in den ersten Teil heute die Frage
stellen was ist Virtualität im Gegensatz
zum Wirklichkeit und Möglichkeit sie
haben bestimmt schon mal die Begriffe
gehört Wirklichkeit Möglichkeit auch
Notwendigkeit muss ich genauer genommen
sagen es ist die modale Frage eine
Modalität ist etwas
logisch zum Beispiel betrachtet werden
kann etwas kann logisch notwendig sein
etwas kann Möglichkeit möglich sein es
kann wirklich sein
Modalitäten ich frag dann aber auch was
es geht und zwar jetzt im Gegensatz zu
illusionssimulation das nenne ich jetzt
die onkologische Frage obwohl
Modalitäten und Ontologie
müssen sie unterschreiben ich glaube ein
Problem der heutigen philosophischen
Ansätze virtuell Universität von denen
es noch nicht so viele gibt ist auch die
erste Vorlesung bei Philosophie der
virtuellen Realität ich zumindest kennen
also ganz neu die unterscheiden nicht
zwischen diesen beiden
Fragen es wird häufig in einen Topf
geworfen ich glaube das ist wichtig das
zu unterscheiden und dann setze ich
beide zusammen wenn wir geklärt haben
was Virtualität ist und was
Realität ist dann brauchen wir was ist
virtuelle Realität und das ist
dementsprechend die modal undologische
Modalität geklärt und die Ontologie und
dann können wir hoffentlich vielleicht
am Ende der heutigen Vorlesung vorläuft
zumindest diese Frage erklären was ist
virtuelle Realitäten jetzt müssen wir
uns aber natürlich erst fragen was es
überhaupt wird und jetzt möchte ich
Ihnen hier ein paar
Meinungen oder Positionen
vorstellen die aus der Philosophie aus
der
Medienwissenschaft Medien Philosophie
darzustellen
Mittelstraße ein Konstanzer Philosoph
folgen
[Musik]
Verwandlung der Welt ein Medienwelt
verbinden gehört vor allem eines
Virtualität
sagt mir Mittelstraße schon im Jahr 2004
also ist das ein Zauberwort ich bin ein
Zauberwort ein Zauberwort das sage ich
nur das Sprechen
und schon ist alles klar oder ich habe
die Aufmerksamkeit oder alle finden es
interessant deswegen sind sie auch alle
gekommen weil ich hier ein Zauberwort
verwendet habe und der Ankündigung
meiner Vorlesen es ist es kommt noch
schlimmer nicht nur Zauberwort sondern
italienische Medien Philosophie sagt das
Verhältnis von Realität Infektion
Fliesen in den Begriff des virtuellen
ein dessen Interpretation kompliziert
ist altes angesichts der pseudo
Vertrautheit mit diesem
[Musik]
mache ich jetzt hier nur modephilosophie
und sie sind nur Mode Studierende glaub
nicht keine Sorge so viel wenn wir
glaube ich schon sagen so ist es nicht
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass wenn ich
allzu schnell dort Virtualität sagen
muss gar keine Virtualität ist
und da kommt die Philosophie wieder
zurück Philosoph
Kritik ja also wir müssen kritisch
darauf achten wie wir unsere Wörter
gebrauchen ich erst seit
was meint eigentlich dieses Wort was
gezeichnet ist überhaupt und da müssen
wir von Wort natürlich übergehen zum
Begriff also was ist die Definition
dieses Phänomens und wir können das
unterscheiden von Verwandten Phänomenen
ich glaube eben zum Beispiel von
Simulationen Illusionen das ist nicht
dasselbe wie virtuelle Realität obwohl
die meisten sicherlich von ihnen sagen
würden natürlich realität ist eine
Illusion Simulation wir kommen auch noch
genauer darauf zu sprechen das ist nicht
klar in der gegenwärtigen Forschung ich
komme doch mal auf Jürgen Mittelstraße
zu sprechen der das ganze jetzt noch ein
bisschen kritischer uns kritischer
sieht er sagt eine längere Zitat was
einmal als Gegensatz zu Realität
verstanden wurde setzt sich an deren
Stelle bzw
eignet sich auf eine zunächst paradox
erscheinen die weiße sein Gegensatz an
es wird Welle war ursprünglich als
Gegenbegriff zu reden verstanden worden
und jetzt tut es virtuelle so als sei es
eigentlich das real das ist der
Gegensatz der Angaben eben dies aber
sollte eigentlich nicht als Aufforderung
verstanden werden munter drauflos zu
spekulieren sondern Nüchternheit und
seine Debatte und technisch erzeugten
neuen Erfahrungswerten zu bringen also
wir wollen jetzt hier in dieser
Vorlesung nicht einfach so drauf los
spekulieren da würde Jürgen Mittelstraße
wie viele zurecht sagen so geht's nicht
nur Modewort so wenig
er bringt uns jetzt hier schon ein
Hinweis virtuelle Realität könnte eine
technisch erzeugte neue Erfahrungswerte
schon mal angeboten er sagt natürlich
noch nicht was es ist vielleicht weiß es
auch nicht
etwa in der Form versucht eine
Definition zu bringen das ist schon mal
philosophisch sehr sinnvoll Realitäten
technisch Erzeugnis soziales und der
Welten
muss das heißen sie bestehen aus einem
künstlichen erzeugten Raum mit sichtbar
gemacht denn Datenstrukturen und Agenten
die durch das Zusammenspiel von
Computern Programmen Vernetzungen und
menschlichen Handlungen wie
wahrnehmenden konstruiert wird darauf
bezieht es sich auf ein Zitat in diesem
Sinne hat der Begriff der Virtualität
ein Zug in revolutionäre
Konstruktionsverfahren und
Trainingsprogramme teleologisch auch
andere Bereiche die Bibliothek lesen
virtuelle Bibliothek und Ökonomie
virtuelle Märkte und so weiter gehalten
der ist total zuzustimmen heutzutage gab
es damals noch nicht zumindest nicht
öffentlich wirksam Bitcoin ja also auch
Finanzmärkten das Finanzsystem das wird
natürlich auch einzuhalten wir müssen
auch in dieser Vorlesung immer mal nach
links und rechts schauen wo macht sich
virtuelle Realität konkretung unserem
Alltag bemerkbar in der Gesellschaft
ssystem in der Wirtschaft da muss man
hinaus werden dennoch müssen wir erst
werden
die Treppe vom Computer machen und
modephilosen jetzt haben wir gehört
Virtualität kann ein Mode ist ein
Modebegriff und wenn ich jetzt hier eine
Vorlesung über die Philosophie der
Wirtschaft Realität anbiete
sehe ich mich zumindest dem Verdacht dem
Vorwurf ausgesetzt ein modephilosoph zu
sein und diesen Verdacht möchte ich
natürlich sehr streuen den möchte ich
diesen Vorwurf sofern er hier im Prinzip
auch irgendwie immer auch anklingen
sollte möchte ich natürlich weit von mir
weisen das heißt ich habe jetzt ganz
schön viel würde auf mich geladen ne
aber argumentationsbürde dass sie am
Ende nicht sagen sie teilnehmenden hier
und die Teilnehmenden auf Youtube ich
mach doch hier eigentlich nur
ich möchte doch jetzt irgendwie nur ein
bisschen aufmerksam geworden
der den habe ich jetzt im Hinterkopf und
der soll mich jetzt motivieren hier
nicht nur die Mode Philosophie zu machen
muss allerdings zur Verteidigung von
modephilosoph Mode Philosophen ich weiß
gar nicht was das genau ist sind es
vielleicht Fernseh Philosophie und
Fernsehen Philosoph ich möchte gar
keinen gewinnen die immer nur zu
aktuellen Themen irgendwas schlaues zu
sagen haben aber in zehn Jahren oder in
zehn Monaten
so möchte ich natürlich jetzt hier keine
Philosophie der virtuellen Realität
präsentieren ich möchte dass die
Philosophie die wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
hier entwickeln dass die auch noch in
einigen Jahren irgendwie idealerweise
Relevanz
überschreiben
ja als Ladenhüter irgendwo
versandet und den Leuten nachgeschmissen
alles wir müssen uns schon anstrengen
schauen was ist das wirklich
substanzielle das was über eine bloße
Mode hinausgeht bei Bitcoin fängt es ja
schon an viele würden sagen
bitte kann es nur
es gibt aber schon Bitcoin Philosophie
und zwar von seriösen Philosoph
hervorragend Philosophen
die wirklich ausgezeichnet sind und die
widmen sich dem Thema Bitcoin aus
philosophische Perspektiven also wenn
schon Bitcoin irgendwie eine eigenen
philosophischen Annäherung Bedarf
offenbar dann umso mehr natürlich der
Überbegriff von Bitcoin nämlich die
virtuelle Realität aber wir müssen
aufpassen nicht nur Mode zu tun nicht
nur kurzfristig zu denken nicht nur
philosophieren entlang von
aktueller Technik die in zehn Jahren
natürlich überholt ist ja denken Sie mal
ich würde jetzt hier eine Philosophie
der Elektrizität anbieten das würde sie
wahrscheinlich irritieren vielleicht
obwohl es spannend ist oder noch
schlimmer ich würde Philosophie der
Glühbirne der der Tat über die die jetzt
verboten wird oder wie Philosophie der
Energiesparen kann jetzt kommen wir die
LEDs ja also Philosophie der LEDs so
wenn man jetzt nicht Philosophie der
virtuellen Realität machen
völlig beliebig in zehn Jahren gibt
Technologie nicht mehr dies überholt
dann ist auch die Philosophie überholt
wenn ich die an einer Technik ausrichte
die überholbar ist das ist so können wir
jetzt nicht Philosophie der virtuellen
Realität betreiben wir müssen uns
grundsätzlichen wir uns wirklich
passahle was eben auch den ganzen Wandel
aller noch kommenden Technologien
übersteht es mögen noch so viele
Headsets jetzt entstehen irgendwann
werden diese Technologien vielleicht in
unseren Körper implantiert und unsere
Brille das heißt das jetzt die virtuelle
Realität irgendwie in einer Brille
realisiert ist oder mit einer Brille das
ist äußerlich das ist Aktien Tele
Kontingent das Spiel für die virtuelle
Realität aber ich möchte trotzdem diese
neuen Medien ernst nehmen nur durch oder
anhand dieser Medien erschließen sich
diese konkreten Dimensionen also es sind
sagen Beispiele
zeitgenössische Beispiele über die wir
wie Medien und diesen Themen gut konkret
anschaulich wird aber wir gehen darüber
hinaus sie bleibt stehen
jetzt möchte ich noch zum Schluss noch
einmal von Jürgen mittel-straße ein
Zitaten weil er sich so gut eignet sich
dafür abzugrenzen
Jürgen Mittelstraße sagt das virtuelle
ist keine Domäne der Wissenschaft
es macht sich auch in der Lebenswelt
breit und guten wie böse hüten wir uns
davor dass in unseren eigenen Köpfen das
virtuelle die Macht über alles reale
gewinnen das Irrationale das unsere
Träume bis jetzt die Macht über das
rational eine Scheinwerfer
neben dem Wissen wohnt nicht nur das
nicht wissen sondern wohnen auch die
Verführung
modephilosophie neben dem Können der
technischen Seite unserer Welt wohnen
auch unsere Albträume neben der Fantasie
die ist gut mit den Menschen meint
virtuelle Realität
Illusion und auch die Fantasie die
Zukunft der Abschaffung des Menschen
feiern jetzt geht es in Richtung Trans
Humanismus haben Sie vielleicht schon
mal gehört kannst du auch posthumanismus
muss man genau unterscheiden
transminismus eine technologisch
inspirierte Philosophie manche sagen
Ideologie
der Mensch muss über sich selbst
hinauswachsen er muss seine biologischen
Natur wenn nicht hinter sich lassen so
doch mit der Technologie verschmelzen
ist eine technologischen Evolution und
er muss am Ende ja das und sterblich
wäre und da stehen natürlich viele
Philosophen dann brauchen sie sagen so
geht's nicht das ist jetzt
allzu problematisch wie über den
Menschen und seine Bestimmung geredet
ich möchte es aber noch einmal darauf
hier eingehen das virtuelle ist keine
Domäne
wenn das so wäre dann könnten wir
eigentlich nicht darüber philosophieren
sofern wir der Auffassung sind das
Philosophie eine Wissenschaft ist auch
ein riesen Thema manche sagen zu Recht
Philosophie ist keine Wissenschaft warum
weil sie keine empirischen Ergebnisse
von wir machen keine Experimente wir
haben keine
objektivitätsstandards wie ist die
Mediziner es ist nicht falsifizierbar
sondern eine philosophische Aussagen es
sei denn sie ist nur gespannt aber wenn
Aussagen logisch nicht philosophische
dann haben wir erstmal ein Problem dann
müssen wir erneut zu verstehen wir
müssen versuchen sie auf ihre Konsistenz
zu überprüfen aber
das Überprüfen eine aussagung eines
Systems auch Konsistenz ist natürlich
was anderes als eine Aussage dafür zu
überprüfen ob sie sich empirisch
bestätigen lässt oder besser gesagt als
sie sehen wenn wir jetzt
Wissenschaftlichkeit mit diesem
tierischen Methoden egal verbinden dann
ist Philosophie gewiss keine wissen
verbindliche Standards also logisch muss
das einwandfrei sein und wir müssen
verständlich schreiben unsere Thesen
müssen wohl begründet sein gute Gründe
natürlich können Gründe verschiedene
sein manche sehen das anders Philosophie
ist kontrovers ganz klar aber trotz
aller Kontroverse hat Philosophie
gewisse Standard und das wiederum
spricht dafür dass es ein bisschen ist
wie auch immer ich glaube das virtuelle
ist nicht nur eine Domäne der
Wissenschaft muss eine Dokumente
wissenschaftszeit und hier ist natürlich
jetzt ein Geschmack dass das virtuelle
als Gefahr oder Bedrohung des realen
gesehen wird nämlich als Steinbildung
und damit müssen uns auch kritisch
auseinandersetzen ich glaube Virtualität
oder virtuelle Realität ist gerade nicht
eine scheinbar
wie genau diese Krise zu verstehen ist
das werden sehen also jetzt haben wir
genug Meinungen uns immer angehört
kritische Ansichten zum Thema virtuelle
Realität und jetzt gehen wir weiter auf
die Frage was ist eigentlich Virtualität
ich möchte Ihnen hier mal schon mal
vorab
ein Handbuch vorstellen
das Handbuch
Virtualität
ist recht neu und sie sehen plötzlich
wird das virtuelle doch zu Domäne der
Wissenschaft weil darüber Handbücher
geschrieben und nicht irgendwelche
Handbücher sondern referenzwerke
die zumindest dich als solche gerieben
wo kann ich sehr empfehlen das können
Sie als Studierende sich kostenlosen
Herunterladen nachdem sich angemeldet
haben
ganz legal verfügbar sind die sagen die
herausgebenden dieses Handbuchs
Virtualität hatten 21 Jahrhunderten
in zahlreichen gesellschaftlichen
war das virtuelle noch bis zum Ende des
20 Jahrhunderts also bis kurz vor dem
Jahr
euphorischen ist apokalyptischen
Reaktionen um den Menschen in Cyberspace
begleitet hat es inzwischen Eingang in
zahlreiche standardisierte Praktiken
gefunden ja was ist denn der Cyberspace
darüber wollen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz
diskutieren ich halte die Aufzeichnung
an und startet damit vorzubereiten
ja wir haben darüber gesprochen dass es
hier gewisse ja Alltäglichkeit gibt die
diese
Praktiken betreffen
hier sprechen die Autoren noch davon
dass das virtuelle nicht länger als ein
Modell ein technisches Eskapismus aus
unserer Lebenswelt zu verstehen ist
sondern dass die würden toyalität
eine kaum übersehbare Fülle von
Szenarien des Einstiegs in und des
Anschlusses an diese Lebenswelt also
Virtualität ist nichts was jetzt eine
nebenwelt bezeichnet wie früher der
cyber-space wo so
[Musik]
Nerds in Kalifornien
unterwegs waren
auf der ganzen Welt sondern das haben
wir alle unsere kostengünstigen in der
nächsten Zeit oder auch jetzt schon
Virtualität ist wie das was wir Natur
nennen oder was lange Zeit zu genannt
wurde Teil unserer Lebenswelt und das in
der Fülle an einer möglichen Bezüge also
Virtualität ist was Alltägliches und
nicht irgendwas was in einem
techniklabor und Kalifornien
starke these weil das jetzt auf dem
ersten Blick nicht einleuchtet diese
Verkabelung diese technifizierung hat
doch jetzt erstmal nichts mit lebenswert
zu tun Technik ist das künstliche weil
das künstliche ist nicht unbedingt das
natürliche wie kann das das künstliche
technische zu natürlichen Wert zum
Alltag wäre das betrifft eine weitere
wichtige Frage die wir in der Morgen
Vorlesung behandelt werden nämlich das
Verhältnis von Technik Technologie und
wird Qualität und leben also Virtualität
bedeutet das Technologie
künstlichkeiten eine Form von
Natürlichkeit oder Alltäglichkeit
gewonnen hat oder es scheint es
zumindest vorauszusetzen
als jede ganz optimistische Auffassung
von Virtualität gegen die These von
Jürgen Mittelstraße gesetzt ja 2004 das
ist um 20 20 15 Jahre sind vergangen und
wir haben eine ganz neue Einstellung
nicht mehr bloße Mode es Kapitalismus
sondern konkrete lebenswerte und sogar
auch nützlich
möchte ich Ihnen so ein paar andere
Beispiele noch bringen die zeigen dass
Virtualität angekommen ist nicht nur in
der Lebenswelt sind auch in Diskurs und
der Wissenschaft Virtualität ist keine
Domäne der Wissenschaft hatten wir
gehört mittlerweile schon
es gibt das Oxford reality
Oxford Handbook also der Oxford
University Press sowas guckt dann müsste
schon was zentrales unter lesen wir die
Zeit ist reason connections mit digital
Domain the
virginity Relation
sind application of modern digital
obwohl das virtuelle ich übersetzt frei
neue Dings mit dem Digital
es ist viel älter hat eine viel längerer
mit Blick auf das real und das wirklich
und diese Ideen der modernen
Digitalisierung
auf der Party also auf der auf dem
Interesse an dieser Wirtschaft also es
virtuelle ist viel älter Virtualität ist
viel älter vielen
geschichtsträchtiger viel
ideengeschichtlich zurückreichen der als
nur die digitale Wirtschaft
starke Thesen das würde jetzt die These
von vorhin vom Handbuch Virtualität
bekräftigen das Virtualität in unserem
Alltag angekommen ist das Handbuch wird
Qualität meint damit aber folgendes ist
es erst um 21 Jahrhundert angekommen ist
nämlich durch die überall verfügbare
Technologie
diese Autoren hier sagen es gab schon
vor der digitalen Technik also im Jahr
500 vor Christus wie kann man sich das
jetzt verstehen wie kann man das jetzt
verstehen wir haben jetzt ganz
verschiedene auch was sagen dahin gehen
was das virtuell ist und seit wann ist
es wirklich gibt also das wird
Verletzung die Autoren ist gar nicht so
neu wie uns die ganzen
technologischen Unternehmen es verkaufen
wollen das virtuelle ist demnach gar
nichts was mit Mode zu tun hat
vielleicht sogar eine alte Wut wenn man
erst richtig entdecken kann
durch die neuen Technologien das wäre
jetzt meine Thesen das virtuelle gab es
schon immer virtuelle Realität ich sage
Ihnen gleich was ich glaube was dazu
gehört nur durch die neuen Technologien
kommt es jetzt besonders zur Geltung
ich sagten gleich was das sein könnte
was es schon zur Zeiten von
Platon gab
ganz einfach das Geld
ist ein virtueller hat ein virtuellen
Wert ein Apfel hat den in der Regel
physisch natürlich kann man sich immer
streiten wodurch bekommt
mit Geld verhält sich aneinander viele
sagen das Geld ist Paradigmen
t gelöst sich vom Füße schon ja
Geldschein hat den Wert den er verbirgt
gar nicht an sich was hat denn ein 50 €
eigentlich für damit meine ich jetzt
physisch wir diskutieren gleich noch
weil ich jetzt auch zeichnen vielleicht
mache ich eine kurze Pause deswegen über
diskutieren also these diese diese
längere Blatt die ist zurückzuführen auf
Phänomene wie z.B das Geld
wir haben also gesehen dass es viele
Theorien gibt die sagen neuere Theorien
dass virtuelle Realität gar nicht so neu
ist wie wir es häufig glauben wenn wir
diesen großen tech-konzernen Glauben
schenken wollen ja also virtuelle
Realität gibt es nicht erst seit der
ba-brille die irgendwie Markt
geworden und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen noch
dieses Zitat
präsentieren das ist ganz ganz zentral
der Autos hat currently days white
straight orchest confusion aber auch
virtual reality and
with contribution
reality potention
das ist eigentlich so das Motto der
Vorlesung zumindest der geborgen
Vorlesen wenn sie Onkologie geht was
sagt der Autobahn es gibt
weit verbreitete und
toologizität und ihr Verhältnis zu der
realen Welt
und das führt zu einem verfälschten
Verständnis virtuelle Realität und ihren
Potenzial
ontologische Konfusion das ist genau das
was wir erleben wenn wir uns fragen
inwiefern ist den virtuelle Realität
real wenn wir doch dann sind
Zustand wenn wir uns vorstellen was
virtuelle Realität ist wenn wir das Wort
haben wir Assoziationen ich komme gleich
noch genau
eine Assoziation ist fake Simulation
scheinbaren eine Scheinwelt Realität
das ist die ontologische Kompression ist
ein Unterschied viele sagen und wir
werden
es ist nicht real,-
etwas kann mir immer als realistisch
erscheinen obwohl es nicht wirklich real
ist
aber damit etwas real ist muss es mehr
sein als nur mehr realistischer schade
deswegen
chemische Erklärung
lässt sich in der
Illusion brauchen eine möglichst lange
Zeit das ist
andere Sache ist mit etwas wirklich ist
und jetzt kann man die natürlich fragen
wie ist es beim Geld ja das Diskutieren
an der Banknote verhält es sich auch so
dass ein 10-Euro-Schein oder der Wert
ist nur realistisch ist aber nicht real
ich glaube nicht oder du würdest sagen
realistisch hat sollte man so über Geld
sprechen oder sollte man lieber so
sprechen er hat wirklich den Wert 10 €
natürlich nur so lange wie es den
Staaten gibt die Europäischen Union
Institutionen gibt die den Unterbau gibt
der diesen Wert am Ende erlaubt zu
konstituieren das habe ich schon ein
onkologischen Begriff gebracht
Konstitution ich habe auch schon andere
Begriff gebracht eine Diskussion nämlich
die der Emergenz das sind alles
antonomische Begriffe zeigen die
natürlich auch geklärt werden müssen
dass zwischen dem Unterbau zum Beispiel
den ganzen Strom Energien und der
Technik Unterbau der am Ende die
virtuelle Realität ermöglicht das ist da
ein Unterschied gibt und das mit diesen
Übergang als
ergänzt oder das Verhältnis als
Konstitution bezahlen kann jedenfalls
ganz wichtig es gibt schon ontologisches
Problem wie existiert virtuelle
Realitäten wenn wir sie nicht nur als
Simulation
verstehen wollen und diese ganzen
Kritiken die wir gesehen haben
Mittelstraße und so weiter die Jüngeren
gerade aus dieser autologischen
Konstruktion weil die zu recht sagen
wenn wir zu tun als ob virtuelle
Realität wirklich führe dabei aber immer
annehmen dass es sich bloß immer die
Simulationen habe dann ist der
Scharlatanerei dann kann ich alles
irgendwie als real,- was ich nur gut
genug simulieren kann und kann ich etwas
für echt verkaufen für wertvoll
verkaufen was aber nur fingiert ist und
dann haben wir in der Philosophie
wirklich ein großes Problem dann geht
uns die Orientierung nicht nur
begrifflich sondern letzte Hinsicht auch
ethisch verloren dann wissen wir am Ende
egal
zu rechnen dabei wollen wir uns jetzt
erstmal beenden lassen wir setzen dann
nachher die Diskussion vor eine schöne
Mittagspause verdient